miki chong dao will not be able to join
us today however we do have dr fermin
lagun
joanne rupert and jeff quinn and we will
now begin
dr again
okay good afternoon
and thank you for being here with us
uh my name is fermin again i'm the
acting chief
health officer for the southern nevada
health street
and today we are
very happy to tell you that this morning
we received our first shipment of the
kobe 19 a vaccine
and this one this is the one coming from
phaser
this shipment is is containing a 12
765 doses of the vaccine
those doses will be delivered to local
hospitals here in clark county
and they will be a minister to her care
providers
through the week we will also
be receiving additional achievements of
vaccine
in the following weeks and uh
and that was thing would be
according to the to the tears already
mentioned by the state if the initial
surprise of vaccine will be provided to
the critical populations identified
by the center for disease control
control and prevention
advisory committee on immunization
practices
joining me today to answer your
questions
and discuss our vaccine distribution
plans
we have a joan piper
who is the director of clinical services
uh also
a jeff queen who is the a manager of our
office of public health preparedness
and also a mickey chondao who is our
community health nurse supervisor
for immunizations mr
corey borges will be facilitating this
call
thank you
we will be happy to answer any questions
that you have about the vaccine
distribution today thank you
if you want to okay here we go first
question is
mary hines you are now
hold on i'm there you go
go ahead good afternoon
when do you expect the first dose of
vaccine to be given
and do you know who will receive that
dose
your mute
do you want your mute up there we go
hello hello everyone
yes we have delivered vaccine
to a local and they will
they are starting to immunize their
hospital employees
so they had them all in line when we
arrived
and so one o'clock they should be
starting
giving vaccine already
one more question from science um
can you please tell us the hospital
uh university medical center
thank you have all the acute care
hospitals received the vaccine at this
time
not yet we're contacting them we we had
a plan in place so we are asking them
if they would like their vaccine earlier
or
do they want to stay on schedule and
we're still determining that
yes joan you might want to to tell them
that
there there was an original schedule for
wednesday
correct yes yes we were expecting a
vaccine either today or tomorrow and we
had a regular schedule
uh set up uh but we
uh we had a hospital that was
ready to go and so we delivered the
vaccine there today
which is umc
this is just a reminder if you would
like to ask a question and you
are joining us you can either type your
question in the chat box
you can hit the raise hand button under
the participants list or if you're just
calling in hit star 9.
we will call on you in the order in
which those questions are received
and we have a question from john traynor
i'm asking you to unmute
yes thank you just two questions if i
could right now
vaccine that needs uh special care when
it's being stored
will that affect its distribution at all
or what steps are being taken
to make sure that vaccine stays as cold
as it needs to
you want me to go ahead dr lagann sure
um
so uh before we have been working with
the hospitals to make sure that they
have that ultra cold storage
and then um they are they have
continuous monitoring of their
temperature and that is reported to
the state immunization office so that
was all in place before the vaccine
ever came so the vaccine was shipped
in a special containers uh with dry ice
and uh then we transported it in that
same shipping container
and then put we can put it in their
freezer
if they're if they do not have a freezer
then we can thought out
and we can also deliver it in its
thought out state which can be kept in
the refrigerator then
for five days
our next question comes from call and
caller ending in 5996
when i meet you please identify yourself
hi jacqueline schultz hi jacqueline
schultz from fox5 here can you talk
about the security measures
in place currently at the sites for uh
distribution
transport what not and uh
how other state and national partners
have been involved in it
oh yeah yeah yeah so um
the security measures that we provide um
for the transport and and dispensing a
vaccine
are pretty standard um we've we've
done a lot of drills and exercises prior
to
receiving covid19 vaccine so we have a
very close working partnership
with our our local law enforcements at
metropolitan police department as well
as the other city
police departments we work
through coordination through the
southern nevada counterterrorism center
to have information sharing between
law enforcement agencies and the
operations that we're conducting
out in the community so for the
transport of this vaccine this morning
we were able to to collaborate with our
partners to arrange transport
and and security for that vaccine
um once the the vaccine was received at
the hospital
umc police officers continue to escort
that vaccine
to where it is ultimately stored
in the future much like the kova testing
sites that we've had
in the community folks will find a
presence
of clark county school district police
las vegas metropolitan police department
officers as well as
north las vegas pd or henderson for
those various venues
next question comes from caller ending
in four eight six
one
hello this is tiffany lane with channel
3. thank you for
taking my question i was wondering we've
been getting a lot of
messages from family members of cobit
patients either
in the er urgent care or in hospitals
they're wondering are they able to get
the covet vaccine and if so
in what tier would that be
the question is about a people who
already
had a code yeah so covet patients who
are either at urgent care or the
hospital
or the er on their family are they
able to get the vaccine and in what tier
well it they they will be able to get
the vaccine
if you know at the time that it is uh
administered to the general population
according to
the the tier where they belong
in into that population
so uh one one of the things that is
that is not clear yet
is how long natural immunity
meaning immunity that is coming from
somebody who
who had the disease how long that
immunity might last
so that's why
the the vaccine will be offered to
to everybody in the community regardless
of whether the person
had the disease before because the
expectation is that the vaccine
protection most likely will be
longer than the one acquired from
natural immunity but again that still is
not
quite clear
i don't know if that answer your
question
our next question comes from john again
yes thank you um a two-parter one
what is the reason for the the early
delivery
um the monday today instead of wednesday
and the second
um question is this all seems like it's
happening very fast uh this is
rapid for getting a vaccine approved
rapid for getting a vaccine delivered
it's amazing but how do you ensure
safety here
before people get it okay i will turn on
you and you can't
okay well the reason for delivering the
vaccine
today i mean from all to the hospital is
because
uh first we didn't have
an exact day of when they were single
right here so we have a time frame
somewhere between monday and wednesday
we didn't know exactly
which one guangana to stay will be
so the vaccine arrived early morning
here today and as soon as they were
seeing arrive
our first step was to notify the
hospitals that they were seeing is here
and and it's available so in this
particular situation
unc it was already
prepared to to administer the vaccine
and they
and they decided to go ahead and start
vaccinating their
employees but
our decision of deploying the vaccine
today
as opposed to waiting for wednesday
uh has no relation with safety of the
vaccine safety devastating
was already established through the
through the field stories that were done
that actually led to the fda approval of
the emergency use authorization
yes and i'll add that our plan was
that it would be uh
that it would be distributed to the
hospitals within 24 to 48 hours upon
receipt of the vaccine
we really weren't expecting it this
early
they even sent an email saying well it's
coming at 10 30 and then
two minutes later we had the vaccine so
we were it was unexpected but um
we did uh we did plan
on it within 24 to 48 hours so wednesday
we knew we'd have the vaccine so that's
how we did a lot of the planning around
that day
our next question is a follow-up from
5996
hi again it's jacqueline with fox 5. i
wanted to ask for the cdc recommendation
pregnant women should consult their
doctor uh
immunocompromised people should not get
it and also
16 and over how uh is that going to be
managed
by the southern nevada health district
and anyone on the front line to
say a pregnant worker who's on the front
line
well um we will follow the series
recommendations so
the vaccine will be offered to
members of this community who are
sitting years old and over which is
one recommendation regarding pregnant
women
that will be an individual case by case
decision and that and the decision is
actually from
from the person in this case for the
pregnant
woman who need to get a buy from her
physician
whether she can get the vaccine or not
and regarding people with a
immune compromise again they will they
will have to to get a buy from from the
from the physician before getting the
vaccine as is recommended by the cdc
so we will follow the cdc
recommendations in that regard
next question is from 4861
hello this is tiffany lane again um just
to follow up
so if um if let's say a patient is in
the hospital on
oxygen or on a ventilator would a
vaccine even
be affect someone who would be
administered a vaccine and would they be
one of the priorities
well i think that the answer to that
question belongs to
to the to the team who is managing that
that particular patient we
what we follow is a general
recommendation which is
which is mostly what we do
with people who are out there in in the
community in ambulatory basis properly
it says so when it when it comes to to
patients who are being managed at the
hospital for
any condition then the decision or
management of that patient
falls into their attending physician
and the team working with that patient
your next question comes from alex
hey there it's alexandra meeks with cnn
do you have a number of how many
hospital personnel at umc
were vaccinated this morning and second
um do you have any details on uh that
you could share about how large the
vaccine shipment was
thanks well yes
um well i know that we took out
um 100 doses to be thought out 105 i
believe
105 to be taken out to be used within
the five days so
i would expect that's what they were
expecting to do today
um there as as many
immunization programs run we start
slower
and then build momentum as we get those
processes
finalized and fine-tuned
we received 12 675 was that
was that the amount which were 13
um 13 bricks of 975 doses
and so that's what we received this
morning
next up jackie kostek
hello um i'm from channel 13. um
my question is we've been talking a lot
about or hearing a lot about uh
potential side effects for
the vaccine and i'm just wondering um
are hospitals deciding
individually how they distribute the
vaccine
amongst the health care providers or is
that is there guidance from you guys
just because
i've seen a lot of places that um you
know hospitals don't want to vaccinate
everyone in one department at the same
time because of possible side effects
and then you know that whole department
being out for a week or something like
that so i'm just wondering if that's
a hospital-based decision or if that's
you guys
no the decision is from the hospital the
organization receiving the vaccine so
they decide
how they want to administer that to
their employees they
you know based on other concerns from
possible side effects they might they
might decide to divide
the employees according to the area
where they work but again the decision
is to eat from the facility or
organization
and we have been talking to them for
three four weeks about this already so
they had a plan
in place and and my understanding is
the individuals who have like the day
off the next day or so
i'm going to take our next question from
tabitha mueller
hello this is tabitha mueller from the
nevada independent
and i had a question about distribute
distribution i was trying to get a sense
of
you know what other hospitals might be
receiving the vaccine today
what does the distribution plan look
like and are any of those
these initial doses going to say cvs
walgreens for distribution to long-term
care facilities
or are we going to be waiting and we'll
or will that come in a separate batch
i know that's a couple questions so i
can follow up follow up
okay um regarding the cbs
our working i believe those
those will be coming next week and
you and you can get this yeah cenius and
walgreen will be receiving vaccine next
week
for the long-term care residents and
staff so that's a whole separate batch
than what we're receiving
um and then we received our
i'm sorry what were the other questions
about the distribution plan the
distribution to the hospitals
we're we're still contacting them right
now
to determine um how they want when they
want to receive their vaccine
keep in mind that there is a lot of
planning you know to
that goes into vaccinating a
workforce so they may decide to wait
till wednesday but
um we're contacting them at this point
right i just want to to add again
that the original plan of distribution
was for wednesday
and that's why we are contacting them
just in case you want to start early
okay i'm going to go to someone who
hasn't asked the question yet this is a
caller ending in 9384
there you go
hi it's cynthia from telemundo sorry for
the delay um
this my question is for dr legend
okay
no gracias
okay okay corey next up we've got
sally from channel eight
hi there my question excuse me
uh my question is a little bit about a
lot of people are obviously
hesitant to get the vaccine i think
we've been talking about that i think
we're well aware of that
um but in particular to the hispanic
community
how are we gonna target uh for them to
get it i know
a lot of people in my community uh
struggle with even just going to the
hospital
so how what are we gonna be doing to let
them alleviate a little bit of that
stress
that they're going through right now
whether they're thinking should i get it
should i not
do i even qualify for something like
this is it gonna cost me
so um anything that you guys have been
uh planning
any strategies see
yeah um well we we have been working
with the county
and also community partners uh
developing a communication plan with the
hispanic
community and also with a community at
large
we also plan in in future weeks
or days to to meet with a
representative for the hispanic
community whether it is you know
a local church or or other
community based organizations and and
ask them to help us deliver that message
we
learned that if
for some segments of the of the of the
community
is it's not it's not enough to to
receive the message through
the the tv attentions or the
registrations or the written
newspapers they they also
need to to to hear from
from their local leaders
so we want to to engage a representative
for the community to help us
deliver that message to the hispanic
community as well
we're going to go back through our list
of follow-up questions now first up is
john thanks i believe this
um vaccine it's two separate shots so
that 105 doses was that
included so 105 people or 105
individual shots and how far between
those two shots
are they administered are they at one
sort of there is there like a booster
essentially
a day or two later well this vaccine
should be
a minister in two dozens
and that should be three weeks apart
it's about 21 to
23 days apart so today
the 105 doses will be 105
individuals receiving the vaccine
yes and this second dose is uh
already accounted for as far as the
vaccine provides
the vaccine suppliers so they have that
dose set aside already
uh when the first doses get them
next up is caller 5996
hi everyone uh jacqueline from fox5
again
wanted to and i know this is a little
more forward-looking
um but for anyone 16
and up how does the health department
plan to administer that
any um thoughts about i know that
there's going to be
larger sites in the future but
especially for tier two is there any
talks about maybe going to
um
and to anyone perhaps 16 and up
and then anything else forward looking
for the public to look forward to
okay um yeah yeah
so yes we we part of our our planning
for the distribution and the rollout of
vaccine
is to have multiple venues and
locations spread throughout the valley
where
not only specific tier groups can get
can get
vaccinated but eventually once we get to
tier four
and we are opening um
a mass vaccination site in the community
um the the venues will be
um much similar to the the covid testing
sites that we've seen
we might uh leverage the the
resort properties that are have not
opened where they have a parking
structure
um it might be local high schools um
definitely community centers and senior
centers
are our locations for uh
providing the vaccine now the fortunate
thing about this vaccine
uh in which is different from when h1n1
mass vaccination the last large venue
mass vaccination event we did in 2008
2009
is that we have a public-private
partnership
so cvs walgreens and other health care
providers
continuously providing vaccine will mean
that the availability of that vaccine
for the general public
will be more more prevalent so
we're optimistic and and very happy to
have received this vaccine so early
and now we can begin the process to work
through the the subgroups within each
tier
and eventually get
quickly down to to the the general
public tier
and i think it's it's a really positive
in our community
uh a lot of the efforts that we've been
doing for covid testing is to slow the
spread
of disease this is now something in in
our toolbox and
arsenal that that can really help help
us prevent
um the the spread of disease
and and get our community back to
working and
and uh resuming some of its operations
pre-covered
we're gonna take just three last
follow-up questions and then we'll wrap
it up for today
first up is the caller ending in four
eight six one
hello um this is a follow-up on the uh
minus
80 uh freezer so talking about that
um i know some universities have some
but how many do we have in southern
nevada are they at the hospitals and the
universities and then
what's the process of delivering those
to the locations does the hospital say
hey i need this many and the university
sends over what's the process of
distributing those vaccines from
those -80 devices
so yes so um there is one at
um unlv we have one and then
uh there are some hospitals that have
the ultra cold
um they are they need to be registered
with the state
first so that we they it can be
monitored
uh correctly and some education uh
with the vaccine so actually
providers that are signed up with the
state can can
order it directly they will not have to
get it through us
uh eventually so a lot of the
ways that you get flu vaccine right now
is going to be available like through
your doctor through the pharmacies
and um and the university uh
plans on vaccinating too as well
uh that's kind of how it works we're it
was just sent to us
first as a for the first time
um so we have a little bit more control
over it
and uh and then from this point forward
we plan on providers getting their own
vaccine
okay our two final questions from today
come from jackie and alex um jackie
you are up first awesome
um so this is similar to sally's
question that she asked about the
hispanic community but i'm just curious
about the healthcare community
um is there any sense of how confident
uh people are in this vaccine it's a
little scary having to be i imagine the
first one exciting but
i imagine there is a little bit of fear
involved as well so have you heard from
any folks that are getting it or um yeah
are choosing not to right we actually
sent out
surveys uh prior to this and uh looking
at
one hospital survey uh it looks like
around
60 70 percent we surveyed our own and we
had a higher
about a similar number and maybe
some other groups on the tier were about
50 50. so
i i think there was a very positive mood
this morning
when we delivered the vaccine and people
seem to be happy
and anxious and ready to get the vaccine
so remember these people are working on
front lines
every day with coded patients and they
can see
the devastation and they can see
what exactly happens so they are very
happy to get the vaccine
to protect themselves
and last question for today comes from
alex
hey there alex with cnn again just a
quick
follow-up to my question about the
hospital personnel at umc
uh that were vaccinated this morning you
mentioned
the shipment arrived around 10 30 and
then staff began
vaccinating shortly after i'm just
wondering if you have
roughly a time that and like was it
immediate
within minutes or hours and
lastly um have all of those 105 that you
mentioned
those vaccines were that were allocated
today have all of those been used
thanks yeah i'm not sure i mean umc
um uh it does take a little bit of time
to vaccinate 100 people
so i'm not sure if everyone in line got
their vaccine yet but
it's my understanding that they plan to
give the
that whole allotment this afternoon um
one thing with the vaccine
um we had to once we put it in the
freezer
and then we take it out we have to wait
30 minutes for it to fall out at least
and then um it has to be diluted and
then used within six hours so
um i we were still on our
i i would say it was 11 30 um
by the time it was in their freezer 11
15 somewhere around that
so they probably started vaccinating
around noon i would imagine
all right thank you all for joining us
today um
get in touch with the office of
communications if we can help you in any
other way
and always remember to continue
spreading the message to mask up
back up and wash up so we can all step
up to slow the spread
of covid in our community thank you all
for joining us
until next time goodbye